Karissa: Almost three years ago,
my life changed.
A powerful EF-5 tornado
ripped through Moore, Oklahoma.
Which, tragically killed
twenty people.
That day,
my friend Dave Holder,
he's a Meteorologist,
and he called me about
forty-five minutes
after the tornado went in.
And he had found a
litter of kittens
that had been displaced,
the mom had, sadly,
been killed by some
flying debris, I believe.
So, he called me, asking
for some advice on what to do.
So, I'm telling him to,
you know,
get them really warm, if you
can put them against your skin,
please do so, you need to
get them to a vet immediately.
Unfortunately, the next day,
three of those kittens,
passed away.
Dave, however, thankfully,
adopted one of the kittens.
And then Shanda,
another friend of mine,
she adopted the
other kitten.
That day the tornado inspired
me to go down a new path.
I decided that I wanted
to help reunite families
with their pets and that has
been my mission ever since.
Within a few weeks of
that mega storm,
I had registered my
not-for-profit organization:
Never Stop Saving.
Chasing tornados introduced
me to many great meteorologists,
other storm chasers,
and just a really
great community of people,
where we could share stories,
kind of be nerds together,
and really just share our
love and crazy obsession
for extreme weather and
the beauty of the natural world.
Around that same time,
a film production company,
called BCII had heard
about us,
and they asked if
they could come out
and film a short clip
of us.
So I said:
"Sure, why not?"
We're already going to
be out there.
So they came out,
and they started filming,
and it was actually
perfect timing,
because they
were able to
film our team as
we bonded,
actually, here is a clip
of our team members
in action as--
on our first deployment as
"Animal Storm Squad".
Narrator:
They arrived thirty miles
outside of the fire's perimeter.
Could be if the animals
that are still alive,
they may have gone to the
safer ground.
We did hear yesterday some
firefighters and other people,
there were some touch-and-go
moments where
they almost got trapped.
Erik: They have no cell data
up there right now.
So we need to make sure
we know where that fire's at.
Winds in a fire drive the fire,
it's like the engine.
The winds will fan the flames,
so as the wind blows higher,
your fire's moving faster,
making it more and
more dangerous.
We're here in Wenatchee
right now,
we know there's a fire
break up here,
so we want to try to
get into the town of Pateros
or the town of Brewster.
Narrator: Disasters are by
definition unique.
Survival and success come
down to being prepared.